oh no
oh no no no no no
[Music]
bro
what is this we're all familiar with
this pesky pop-up not only is it
annoying but for being honest it's kind
of hard to before you just had to click
a checkbox or type out some blurry text
but now you have to identify the
motorcycle or the crosswalk or the
invisible donkey apparently these
obtrusions are supposed to protect
websites from Bots hackers and AI but it
looks like the only visitors that it's
actually blocking or frustrated users I
mean if AI is Advanced enough to produce
this and this surely it can get through
this and this right well the answer is
yes most modern AIS can easily bypass
Modern captchas in fact such AIS have
become so common that AI researchers
have started to name their captcha
solvers yet another text capture solver
and that itself was five years ago also
you don't even need to know coding or
develop AI to outsmart these suckers
instead you can just use cheap labor
from overseas to track millions of these
for virtually no money in fact there are
full-on companies that are centered
around offering exactly this the most
notable of these is a company called
tukapcha who charges just one dollar for
1 000 capture solves you basically just
need these 10 lines of code here and
it'll route whatever capture you're
trying to crack to some Sweatshop in
Asia and boom you suddenly have the
ability to crack a million captures for
less than the price of a new iPhone
ironically this is not only more cost
effective than hiring someone to develop
an AI for you but it's actually even
more reliable after all the people
solving these captures are actually just
real people but if such Solutions are so
accessible and widespread why in the
world are websites still making us solve
these increasingly difficult puzzles
well it turns out that captcha is not
only an easy Revenue driver for Google
but it's a gold mine of data and
millions of hours of Free Labor way back
in 2007 itself 16 million captures were
being completed every single day so this
number is likely in the hundreds of
millions today most of which goes
through Google Google ironically charges
the same amount as the captcha solvers
one dollar per thousand solves so with
let's say 300 million captures per day
Google would be pulling in 110 million
dollars per year not a bad amount for a
service that doesn't accomplish much but
that money is nothing in comparison to
the data here's the thing what sort of
website would be most likely to
incorporate cab chop well the answer is
websites that offer some sort of
valuable service whether that be a
newsletter a waiting list or an online
purchase this data point that you use
this service is way more valuable than
the random Google search you made about
how to be more popular and thanks to
captcha Google is able to get their
hands on a few hundred million of these
data points every single day so here's
how captcha went from being a failing
security measure to being one of
Google's most valuable data collection
Avenues
foreign
interestingly enough Cactus weren't
invented to stop hackers they were
actually invented by hackers to get
around content screening and filtering
you see back in the 80s and 90s
computers couldn't read text inside
images very well especially if they were
squiggly so obscure images with the text
became the go-to way for dubious people
to communicate about Shady topics online
without triggering any content filtering
algorithms hackers were to take this
even one step further by incorporating
something called leadspeak you know how
you can type hello wanna calculator
using numbers well it turns out that
there is actually a name for this lead
speak and there is an official way to
use it computers weren't very good at
interpreting leadspeak either so
leadspeak plus squiggly images became
the go-to way to communicate about
nefarious topics online eventually
though at the turn of the century this
would catch the eyes of someone from the
other side Carnegie Mellon University a
couple of researchers here figured that
if this strategy could be used to trick
computers for bad things it could also
would be used to drink computers for
good things one of the biggest issues
online at the time was spam Bots and it
was way worse than we have it today
nowadays spam Bots are usually just
annoying and they tell you to contact
them through WhatsApp but back in the
day spam Bots were spreading deadly
viruses like I love you infecting tens
of millions of computers and causing
billions of dollars worth of damage so
naturally these researchers wanted to
limit Bots from accessing certain
resources which led to the creation of
captcha in 1999. captcha stands for
completely automated public Turing tests
to tell computers and humans apart and
it was basically just a piece of code
that could generate these seemingly
harmless but infinitely frustrating
tests at first though it wasn't too bad
in fact it was actually easy for humans
and hard for Bots with humans boasting a
success rate of 97 saying this it didn't
take long for entrepreneurs to start
implementing this technology into their
own platforms the first of which being
max levitchin if you're not familiar
with Max he was one of the co-founders
of PayPal and was serving as the
company's CTO at the time PayPal was a
prime target for hackers due to their
generous new account bonuses of 10 to 20
dollars and let's just say the company
was burning a boatload of money trying
to keep up this promotion for real users
when a PayPal engineer named David
gosbeck would have an epiphany why not
use that hacker thing to fight hackers
he would email his idea to Max that
night and that by the time he got to the
office the next day max would already be
done with half of the development from
there it didn't take long for PayPal to
push out the future in 2001 and it
quickly became an internet staple as
everyone from eBay to Google adopted it
for years it seemed like this was the
perfect solution to stop Hackers from
wasting resources and causing damage
online but this golden period it didn't
last forever
foreign
with all these Mega companies trying to
block hackers you would think that they
would have no chance but time and time
again this would be proven false and one
of the main reasons for this is that
hackers simply have a far better risk to
reward ratio if they're able to get
through the security of Google or Apple
they have their Prospect of making
millions if not tens of Millions for
Google and apple on the other hand while
such losses are somewhat annoying
they're by no means a top priority it
makes far more sense for them to focus
on protecting market share and creating
the next big thing as this is worth a
billions if not tens of billions So
eventually hackers and researchers would
both develop AIS and the programs that
could crack these relatively simple
questions and it became clear that
captchas needed to be taken to the next
level but it didn't make sense for each
company to develop these increasingly
difficult captures by themselves it was
simply way too much effort what the
industry needed was a centralized
service with a dedicated team that could
always stay one step ahead up hackers
enter Google in September of 2009 Google
would acquire recaptcha from the
original Carnegie Mellon researchers for
an undisclosed amount honestly it was
probably a really small amount for
Google maybe 5 or 10 million but given
that the researchers were having trouble
trademarking their findings their only
alternative to making more money was to
build a flawed company around this
Google would instantly turn around and
200 IQ this yes they were to go ahead
and use it for data collection but we'll
get to that later they actually had a
200 IQ move way before that why generate
useless pieces of text for people to
transcribe it when you can get them to
transcribe it useful pieces of text you
see it around this time Google was
trying to digitize the entirety of the
world's newspapers and the books for
Google books but it turns out that it
was quite difficult for computers to
optically recognize text from older
books and newspapers so Google decided
that it would be a great idea to
incorporate these hard to read words
into capture tests for one if Google's
AIS themselves could not decipher them
it was unlikely that malicious ones
could Google could literally get paid by
websites and companies to transcribe
these old books using free labor and
lots of it back in the day itself people
were solving 60 million captures every
single day and even if we assume that it
only takes 5 seconds on average to
complete we're talking about over 83 000
hours of Labor every single day if
Google wanted to hire this same amount
of Manpower they would have to hire over
000 employees even at a minimum wage
that would cost them 145 a million
dollars per year but using this strategy
Google was getting paid to do this and
this takes us into the era of Google
capture
foreign
book idea gave them free labor for years
but eventually their AIS did become
Advanced enough to decode any piece of
text leading us to our modern conundrum
at first Google would try to address
this issue in the most obvious way
possible just make the captcha harder
but by 2014 it became clear that this
just wasn't gonna work capjust had
already become the opposite of what they
were supposed to be instead of being
easy for humans and hard for Bots they
were hard for humans and a joke for Bots
Bots were passing text captures at 99.8
of the time while humans were only
succeeding 33 of the time clearly text
captors had reached the end of their
useful lives prompting Google to create
the famous I'm not a robot checkbox the
idea of this new captcha was that
instead of trying to test the
intelligence of humans it would test the
imperfectness of humans I know a lot of
us like to think that we're Mouse
aficionados with our fancy gaming mice
but it turns out that humans actually
suck at using mice if you zoom into a
mouse movement there's actually a lot of
Quivers shakes and the general
Randomness a bot on the other hand is
able to click on the checkbox with a
precise Mouse movement or even no mouse
movement at all but this would be a
mistake because Google is actually
looking for our imperfectness this was
not only a brilliant solution but it was
easy for people to use this system
doesn't really work on mobile devices
because there is no mouse so Google
turned to creating a better version of
the original text captcha Bots had
become really good at deciphering text
but they couldn't yet decipher images
like crosswalks and invisible donkeys
and this led to the creation of the
modern captcha that we all hate today
things didn't get better from there
either it didn't take long for Bots to
be able to mimic the imperfect Mouse
movements of humans and this led to the
picture capture being ported over to
computers as well but as you would guess
this too was quickly solved actually use
Google's own image recognition
technology to crack the captcha so more
recently Google has opted to completely
ditch test altogether with recaptcha
version 3. instead it the captcha is
invisible and is constantly tracking
your interaction with a given website to
assign you a dynamic risk score between
0 and 1. website owners can set a
threshold under which users will be
denied access to the given resource but
it's not really clear how effective this
really is so captchas have become
virtually useless but if that's the case
why in the world does everyone still use
captcha
foreign
s are no longer that great at stopping
Bots but this isn't to say that they
don't have any value for anyone for
Google captcha offers tremendous value
before they were able to train their
text recognition technology and the
digitized books using captcha now
they're able to collect in millions of
hours worth of human image recognition
and a general website usage data that
can be used for machine learning and
training Ai and it doesn't stop right
there either Google is also able to
collect data about our most important
online activity for obvious reasons our
most important online activity is
usually the stuff that's guarded by
captchas giving Google direct access to
the specific data which is way more
valuable than our general online usage
so it's no wonder why Google continues
to push captcha and to put resources
behind it but what about companies and
websites why use something that's not
even effective well the primary reason
is why not you see it as captcha became
less and less effective Google became
more random more generous with their
free tiers for companies currently
Google offers the first million calls to
captcha every month for free and most
websites aren't protecting access to the
website itself with captcha usually
captcha is used to protect new account
creation joining a waitlist subscribing
to a newsletter Etc and even the best
websites in the world will only have a
conversion rate of 11 meaning that you
would need to have nearly 10 million
visitors to your website every single
month before Google even charges you a
dime and even after that they're only
going to charge you around a thousand
dollars for every additional attendant
million users so it's really only the
mega billion dollar companies that are
paying Google for captcha and it's a
pretty negligible cost for them as well
so why not use it sure it may let 90 or
even 99 of bots pass right on through
but it costs next to nothing or
literally nothing and it may stop a few
bots on occasion and they give a bit of
extra security not to mention it
everyone else is using it so using it
will make your website look more
reputable and that's why everyone still
uses capta despite it being horrendously
ineffective and annoying do you hate
captures comment that down below also
drop a like if your socket captures as
well and of course consider checking out
our Discord Community to catch up your
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions are logically
answered but until then I'm hurry and
I'll see you guys on the next one
foreign
[Music]